math and physics are two very similar
subjects and they're quite intertwined
with each other especially from the
physics point of view a physics major is
going to be required to take a bunch of
math courses along their program because
you need to know the max to be able to
do the physics in the first place a lot
of physics is trying to describe a
physical system by formulating it in
terms of math or equations and then
seeing how that system evolves or what
changes to the theoretical model are
going to result in I guess changes in
the physical world on the other hand if
you're a math major you probably aren't
required to take physics courses in your
program but a lot of math majors
probably are interested in at least some
aspects of the physical world so I think
what is actually important is that there
are two main flavors of physics one is
experimental and the other is
theoretical physics and they can be
actually quite different but they
usually come hand-in-hand so in a
physics department at a university most
of the work has probably got an
experimental Bend to it but it's going
to be rare to find a project that is
purely experimental without at least
developing some theory behind what's
going on some aspects of this purely
theoretical physics would actually
happen in the math department so that's
going to include ideas you might have
heard of like string theory string
theory is actually purely mathematical
in a sense because it doesn't yield
results that you could test in a
physical experiment it's only things you
could essentially test with equations
similar ideas I think would be aspects
of general relativity that deal with
differential geometry so essentially
shapes and how they're changing and how
we can use them to describe the universe
so whilst it these ideas do have
applications to physics and explaining
the world around us
actually you'd find this work going on
in math departments so if you kind of
know that you want to end up in that
purely theoretical side of things I'd
probably say you'd be better off doing a
math major than a physics one the
physics major I think sets you up really
well to do more of an experimental kind
of work maybe like a lot of your courses
will be lab work writing lab reports
dealing with things like thermodynamics
electronics electromagnetism and
mechanics so that you can actually build
and test theories in the physical world
and see how things are working yes so I
think that's sort of the difference
between the majors but it's hard to know
when you sign up to uni which one you'd
want to end up working in more so I
actually did a double major in both
mathematics and physics and look I
wouldn't say that I would necessarily
make recommend that I actually don't
think your majors matter too much per se
in the end I think they're just a line
on your degree but they don't define
what you have to do in the future so I'm
doing an experimental project now I
probably don't use much of the math I
learned at all but I'm still glad that I
did it and the reason I did the double
major wasn't planned it was just that I
kept taking courses that I was
interested in and it sort of ended up
that by the end of my degree I had taken
enough courses to fulfill the
requirements of both these majors
separately but in order to do that I did
over point almost every semester and
over pointing means taking more than the
full-time load of courses so in my case
that was taking five courses every
semester instead of four now there's no
reason you would over point it doesn't
give you any like benefit or advantage
other than that you can do it if you
want to and I just wanted to do it but
cause I when I over pointed I was taking
courses that just seemed really
interesting to me so whether it was
taking an extra course and group theory
or computer science or the history of
mathematics all these courses I just saw
and I just I didn't want to pass them up
I thought it would be a shame if I
didn't learn about that topic like I
just really wanted to learn them and I
knew the best way for me to learn them
was to take them as an extra course sure
you could have liked taught yourself
some of that knowledge but I felt the
best way for me to actually get involved
in them was to just take them as an
extra course I guess for me I found it
doable to do five courses every semester
but if you're already like stressed or
have a lot of like extra commitments or
work or something that it's probably not
a good idea to take more courses than
you need to yeah I think it was just
something that I I did it at the time
and I'm glad I did it because I did
learn a lot by taking those extra
courses and I'm know it was cool to get
the double major but it's probably not
necessary by any means I think no matter
if you major in physics or in math
they're so similar really that you can't
just need to sell to your future
supervisor or to your future employer
the skills that you gained and just I
don't know in terms of if you want to go
into grad school and do a PhD afterwards
and you're worried should you do physics
or maths it doesn't matter like you just
need to like it doesn't matter what
major you do you could do anything you
could do philosophy even you just need
to be able to convince that supervisor
to take you on as a student
and to do that I think who you are as a
person and your interest in learning and
doing research is way more important
than whatever line is on your degree of
like what majors you had so keep that in
mind I hope it helps thanks for watching